if you're a operator you can operate
around new truths sometimes that's the
consumer Behavior sometimes that's a
political organization but the reality
is you do have a lot of control
including things like you know there's a
global audience like
you can leave where you live if you're
in Sweden right now and you're like man
if you it's harder to build a huge
company in Sweden in Tech I'm like move
to San Francisco
could and so I I really do love the
happiness that comes along with
accountability vaynernation how are you
very excited about this podcast uh I
always like when I'm starting new
pillars new genres new Concepts this
concept of interesting emerging
entrepreneurial stories is something
I've been bouncing around and I met this
young gentleman uh in Utah right
absolutely yeah Salt Lake um and uh we
we apt we got some stuff brewing and it
and it really just kind of sat with me
for a while because I think that was in
February
um about like oh I I should have him on
the podcast he'd be a great kickoff for
this thing that I want to do so first
because I know a lot of you have uh
really cool interesting backstories and
have emerging entrepreneurial Ventures
I'm excited to have many of you in the
future years in this hot seat to tell
your story
um obviously on this podcast a lot of
times we get to see the finished product
you know we get a lot of cool people
writing their book of their whole career
or you know or at the top of their game
but I really want to start putting out
content because I think it's going to
really matter to my audience this
audience about individuals that I see
have the potential to be the type of
people that in 20 years have books about
their life story or their career but we
catch them in the beginning of it or in
the middle of it or the early middle of
it and so that's what today represents
I'm excited about this conversation and
I'd love to get feedback from all of you
on Twitter or email or DM me on what you
think about this genre so kicking off
our first episode in this concept of
interesting emerging entrepreneurial
stories my friend why don't you tell
everybody your name what you do and
we'll go into it and thank you for being
the kickoff first guest to this concert
sure thanks Gary thanks for the
opportunity to talk about my story my
name is Anthony to Sony you can call me
a t I'm the co-founder and CEO of trulio
we do police body camera analytics yes
and my back ground is south side Chicago
big family brothers or veterans became
FBI agent I didn't I went to college and
I did Quantum and one number number
three The Negotiator yes and number
first who did that uh so my oldest
brother and my youngest brother are
veterans got it and I went to college
and did Quant Finance yes ended up on
Wall Street yes building trading
strategies and looking for signal and
unstructured data they signed on the
dotted line and served the country and
uh now are in FBI and um and so I'm
super proud of them yes from a proud
military police family and when I spent
a lot of time dealing with unstructured
data looking for Signal built my first
company before you go there yeah why did
you gravitate towards math as a kid was
it Wall Street
strategies was the Wall Street thing a
money thing for you as a kid
um like you were like I like games I
like math I like stats oh and now that
I've become way of this Wall Street
thing I can take those skills and it can
also be a financial thing sure I like to
win in games and uh trading is a big
game it's like a video game and so um
yeah like probability and stats I
thought I needed math I learned a lot of
math doing Quant Finance you then you
grow up and you learn that the world is
not linear or deterministic a plus b
equals c but not in the real world uh
and and so I learned through building
trading strategies that game theory is
actually more important to making money
than
formulas the gray of psychology yeah
understanding herd mentality yeah how
people think and
um and having a Trader's mind says
definitely helped me as an entrepreneur
helped me understand how to manage risk
how to think about losing trades whether
it's like a bad hire or a decision I
made that isn't working really allows
you to separate yourself from ego how
old are you right now 41. so at 41 how
would you say you balance the gray and
the black and white that you've just now
talked about in the first couple seconds
like if I asked you and obviously every
scenario is going to be different but
just gut feel in your stomach right now
when you are making decisions because I
think this is going to be very powerful
for a lot of people who are listening
making decisions is like such a big part
of it all you know and I think some
people a lot of people really gravitate
towards one side or the other it's all
it's all black and white lender or it's
all like gut feel what what do you think
your current mix is in your current
state it became more gut as I've gotten
older yeah how do I feel about this
person sitting across from me yeah I I
really think the key to making good
decisions is your Clarity of thought it
has to be grounded in reality meaning
you have to ask a lot of good questions
to understand what actually is reality
and I learned over time that My Success
was highly correlated to the Quality
questions I ask in a meeting do you
think that a lot of people are grounded
in ideology yes I think a lot of
people's egos in the way they don't you
know they're thinking about their
business they're not being realistic
that it's suffering in some way that
there's some damage that it's not doing
as well that it could fail and they've
convinced themselves of a different
reality often not being accountable and
liking
somebody else yeah my favorite thing is
when Entre I talk to so many this is a
big one for everybody who's listening
when you come and tell me your business
is failing because of these two people
that work for you you do understand that
you were the one who hired them and you
were the one that is deciding to let
them still be there
yeah yeah it's a you're 100 responsible
for your business period 100 percent
one of my favorite things is
into entrepreneurs over the last 15
years is their passion for who the
president is as if that's a proxy to how
successful they are as an entrepreneur
I'm aware that taxes could change under
different presidencies I'm aware that
policies can and you know I'm aware that
there's rules that can be made but the
reality is still at the end of the day
if you're a operator you can operate
around new truths sometimes that's the
consumer Behavior sometimes that's a
political organization but the reality
is you do have a lot of control
including things like you know there's a
global audience like
you can leave where you live if you're
in Sweden right now and you're like man
it's just harder to build a huge company
in Sweden in Tech I'm like move to San
Francisco
could and so I I really do love the
happiness that comes along with
accountability my my gut instinct I
think became more honed as I got older
as I had to hire people I think during
the hiring processes it's not as black
and white it's very difficult difficult
to quantify or structure an interview
and we need to spend time with people
yeah yeah but but there are things you
should be looking for there are certain
questions you should be asking or even
more interesting to me has always been
and then there's you've hired them and
then the process actually begins right
the data gets very clear when you're
actually with someone you know hiring
even to your point even if you have a
good process there's still going to be
so much of an intuitive guess
yeah you're not going to bet a thousand
not even close
working with someone the data becomes
dramatically more clear so what you do
about it once you realize you've made a
poor hire or a great hire yeah really
becomes the variable of growth you need
to eliminate poor hires especially a a
small startup like trulio I owe it to my
team my investors my customers and that
person if they're not the right person
to be at the company it's not right for
them or their family or their growth and
so it's better just have that obvious
conversation let's back back all the way
back up where I distracted us and took
us off the course so okay so you're
trading then what happens
um yeah so I'm building trading
strategies you know systematic approach
to trading all model building everything
is
um you know nothing's discretionary I
build systems and so I work on Wall
Street and I learned to do something
called natural language processing which
is essentially transcribing and
analyzing calls I was very interested in
in structuring all the different
conversations I had at one point I had
180 counterparties that I would talk to
and I wanted to make our conversation
searchable so that if somebody called me
and asked for Coca-Cola I could search
who who else asked me for this product
in the past
and so I was very interested in
structuring unstructured data email chat
messages most a lot of trading is still
done over insta message believe it or
not and so um I learned about natural
language processing and I ended up
forming a company simply because I was
pissed off that trading you're worth 1X
multiple Revenue there's no there's no
multiple on your Revenue trading forces
you to be a very Perpetual learning
learner because strategies Decay so fast
after nine months a strategy is
irrelevant and that's because everyone
catches up to the strategy because
trading today is like Star Wars I mean
people use AI yeah inefficiencies are
spotted quickly and so extracted quickly
yes yes so you need to be uh you need to
evolve and adapt very quickly uh and and
it's a lot of work and you're still
going to be worth 1X multiple there's
there's no SAS No One's Gonna acquire
you for your trading multiple or trading
revenue is what occurred last year and
so right around 30 I started my first
Company Green Key and we transcribed and
analyze Banker phone calls and we gave
the bank client insights you know what
what are their customers calling for
what are they upset about how do you
hire better sales people product
whatever it is yep yeah how do you
create better objection handling we were
structuring the unstructured data yep
and give us a little bit more of how
that went sure so um I I've made a lot
of mistakes in my life of course uh one
big mistake so is every single person
listening the number one problem that a
Founder entrepreneur needs to solve is
what is the problem you want to solve
that's it like that everything starts
with the problem you're choosing to
solve because everyone you're going to
have to work hard but the how you direct
that hard work is very important the
problem we try to solve looking back on
it we were solving a problem for banks
that we thought would move this data to
the cloud they didn't we made a lot of
assumptions that were bad another big
assumption we made was that did you make
assumptions out of what you knew would
be better but didn't understand that the
customer wasn't ready yes but also you
know I wanna I apologize I jumped in
noticed everyone even just rewind this
and start where you know two minutes ago
and just keep listening the reason I was
able to jump into that is talk about
pattern recognition no different than
people living on ideology versus reality
when I tell you the single thing that I
see over and over a very capable talent
in startup land is knowing what is
better
but getting there too fast for the
market because the market has other
rationales where the best technology or
the best thing isn't the actual North
Star there's some sort of other
rationale Legacy software contracts
political relationships in the business
sense of political relationships so
keep an eye out for that you might be
right but you might be so early or you
might have been naive to how people make
decisions that's exactly right
timing is everything the customer might
not be ready for you to solve their
problem in the way you want to solve it
correct and so um one of another issue
with that business was that we would do
a great job for JP Morgan and guess what
they would pay for us and say don't tell
anybody about how this works so there
was no viral coefficient we couldn't
build on that success they didn't want
Goldman Sachs to know what we just did
right and so that's very different than
for example in policing where I do a
great job for one department and they
tell 50. but if you do a bad job they
tell 100 right and so but I like that
business I like a business where I can
compete on quality of service product
yeah absolutely let's actually segue to
that so that one that business had a
story just quickly how did that wrap up
sale Old what eight years it was
acquired in 2021 okay and you were happy
with that yes good and so then you have
you sell a business that you were happy
about so that's good so that means what
was you said 2021 yes so very recently a
year and a half ago yeah so you're 39 40
whenever this you know goes down
what's running through your mind post
that exit and how does that play into
what you're doing now
um the the problem of police trust being
low I thought about it was obsessed
about it I I like thinking about
problems that Society has that it
doesn't yet know how to get the solution
to right and so trust in the police is
low for a lot of different reasons and I
thought actually I'm in a very unique
position to maybe solve that problem so
I began to research it I went around to
the camera providers right the people
that manufacture body cameras and I said
hey guys NLP is uh eight years old at
this point transcription's 30 years old
why aren't you guys analyzing body
camera video I wanted to figure out why
no one else was doing it you're asking
the questions yeah doing a lot of
research went around and met with
various Chiefs went to the FBI National
Academy which is the top gun of policing
met with the top one percent of police
hey guys this is what I think the
problem is I think this is how I can
solve it what do you guys think just
doing a lot of q a you already have a
lot of nuances and hypotheses because
you got your brothers around you and so
it's you know between research and then
kind of like listening to the stories
and I'm sure whatever that was you're on
a hunch and then you're confirming
hunches with more questions and you're
going through this process how long does
that go
um that that goes for about six months
and what happens at the end of that six
months what's the Eureka or the IC
signal I get access to data yeah I look
at unstructured data I quantify cops
language and I see in the data
cops that give more explanation have
better outcomes before we go down this
which I think is super fascinating I
want you to go back to the the natural
language stuff as a whole because it's
at the foundation of where you're about
to go and we have so many different
people listening there's going to be
like the people that are generally just
interested like I am which is probably
why you're here of like hey this is
really cool to like solve some of life's
biggest dilemmas through technologies
that are merging with AI and everything
else coming there's like a whole new
world order of the next one like I can't
wait to watch from heaven like the next
hundred years we're gonna do a lot of
cool [__]
but then there's also like the nerdiness
of this there's a lot of people that
could find their calling because of this
break down the natural language so for
just a quick second we'll go back to
where we are on the police stuff but I
think you know watching videos
transcribing the words and then
structuring that to like actually get
into an ahas or six is really cool yeah
I understand so um so most of the
electronic communication between
computers is done over protocols or it
had been right so you write to an API
there's a protocol there's a format for
these two strings to be passed back and
forth they have to be in a certain order
and that's how the world worked
primarily but that's not how humans
communicate we we communicate in an
unstructured way through language and
video and and chat and some message and
all this and so language yeah so NLP
natural language processing it's a it's
a subfield of AI it's like the
intersection of linguistics where
basically it structures language so that
a machine can understand not just the
the word spoken but the sentiment and
the meaning behind it so NLP is being
used to for example summarize a document
it can be used to label documents where
okay these words are empathy this is
questioning this is uh you know
different types of labels that created
like in trulio we create labels around
an arrest use of force non-compliance
and so categorizing you categorize the
insights which is how humans are
actually conveying we're conveying these
large insights back and forth so NLP is
just a way to structure unstructured
data so machines can process it
it's like an interface humans and
machines
um with ML and LP like all of this stuff
is like for a long time I'm like man
this is a because for me all my magic
was in the gray and an intuition and so
like when this all started hitting my
radar four seven eight years ago I'm
like wait a minute yeah I'm glad I'm
gonna retire because my magic can
actually become commoditized over time
which is profound yes it's profound like
everything that has worked for me yeah
so it's like actually going to be
mapped yeah that's exactly right it's
structured in in like an Excel
spreadsheet NLP makes data come alive
and be able to be structured so it can
be analyzed and compared so you go
through this journey yeah you start
analyzing the videos yeah and you're
like [__] I got stuff yeah yeah yeah
Traders mindset sifting through a bunch
of unstructured data thinking about
should I start this company well I need
to know that there's signal I need to
know for sure because there's a lot of
noise I'll give you some examples you
could I had to break down signal and
noise because I'm sure of it but I feel
like people can get a lot of value if
you're breaking down sure so you know
signal or Alpha is like looking at data
sets and and finding causation and it's
like an example would be in the data
sets we mine you could say well you know
I don't want Cops to say swear words
well I got news for you it was super
they're super effective cops that say
swear words we can look at their data
and I'll find a civilian gratitude uh
they've got good outcomes even though
that they use some profanity and so that
we realize well actually it's directed
profanity it's the fu to somebody that
they don't like of course and humans
civilians don't like insults watch this
everyone Dustin let's go [__] kill it
together yeah versus Dustin [__] you
[__] exactly yep thank you yeah
so we had to sift through noise and look
for what is the actual signal what what
is it that
creates good outcomes for cops and
civilians here's another example the
number one complaint from a civilian
four cop is he was rude he or she was
rude to me what that means in the data
is that the officer gives commands and
doesn't negotiate there's no listening
there's no what about this we don't
monitor tone I want to tell you why you
can do it tone Cadence volume clipping
frequency all this stuff there's not
enough signal there got it because
there's loud cops that are respectful
and effective and so I don't think the
science what about their intent
boy if you know I'm sorry uh podcast I'm
apologizing right now I'm getting very
selfish
it's insane to me how much the currency
of my bro like my being believes that
intent
is like this Prof like it's unbelief I
basically make every decision based on
my interpretation of the intent
is that something that can factor in or
is that just too [__] hard I had this
point we can't do it I don't know if
anybody can do it we can't and my job as
CEOs make sure we only work on the
things that we're going to do really
well and we can't do that well we can't
do image analysis well so we don't work
on those things yeah it's funny as
Vayner media as the agency we're sitting
in right now I think one of the re
people somebody asked me the other night
he's like man
you guys literally built one of the
biggest agencies of all time in such a
short period of time like how and I'm
like you know there's a lot of answers
but it was funny it was similar to what
you just said I was like you know
self-awareness I was really really clear
in my brain of what we could do
exceptionally well compared to everyone
else and what would be a commodity or as
good as everyone else or below it
everyone else so I really love hearing
that it's a real big insight for all the
founders listening understanding that
not doing things you think you have to
do because everyone else is doing it
focusing on strengths versus trying to
like half-ass weaknesses you need to
protect your company with the word no
customers are going to ask you a lot of
to do a lot of crazy stuff and bolt on
different solutions you need to say no
to that stuff and say stay true to
yourself yeah because then your product
becomes Frankenstein then your
Professional Services yeah I think those
record multiples so you're going through
and and you're you're seeing it I mean
this is that must feel like a um what's
that brother yeah elated yeah yeah not
only elated pretty emotional because you
know look I'm trying to do great
advertising Communications and that's
important and obviously when I do it for
non-profits versus for-profit like
there's a different feeling but like
you're not [__] around here like this
is a big one like God forbid which I
mean God willing I use it as slang you
map this one you get this at scale like
you're gonna do a lot of good for the
world talk about getting this right that
just helps a lot
yeah yeah we're super excited about our
mission
um you know the the vast majority of
police do a pretty good job there's some
percentage that shouldn't be cops but
this gives them a map a protocol a
structure of uh an algorithm to follow
it's very simple to follow we give them
the rules of this video game they play
the game they structure their strategic
language around it and they're gonna
have better outcomes how many cops in
America were around the world today wear
a body well in the U.S there's about a
million cops and about 650 000 700 000
of them wear cameras really high number
yeah it's not it's not 100 yeah they
still don't have cameras in rural
counties and things
every major city has cameras
and how many like can
there's probably not a huge there's very
few humans on Earth that are more
optimistic about humans than I am it is
what keeps me so happy I believe in team
human so much it's crazy I'm also aware
that the small percentage of humans that
don't hold up to a level of humanity
that we all aspire to or eating up the
oxygen of the conversation thus
rendering a lot of people feeling
unhappy because I think the noise around
the one or two percent that aren't doing
it well clouds us to understanding that
98 of people are good people doing the
thing and so and that comes in every
form parenting politics teachers police
on on and on relationships so your point
earlier like most cops are doing it
really right some people shouldn't be
and then there's probably some sort of
thing in the Middle with a little
tweaking and training could get to the
side that you wanted to and so I mean I
assume this is a massive tool for whom
the chief
yes a chief would use it to sort of
mitigate risk right they want to go to
sleep at night but the tools designed
for the sergeant the Sergeant's
responsible for eight or nine people
called their squad and it gives the
sergeant the ability to do some coaching
to identify moments of non-compliance or
any unprofessional language to intervene
and say hey cut that out uh and and
during non-compliance hey I notice you
interrupt this person I noticed that you
gave a lot of commands they asked
questions you didn't give explanation so
it's really a tool designed to help the
sergeant how much is bad behavior that
isn't on like what is ideal predicated
on fear
most of it yeah so these young cops that
give a lot of commands that's what's
going on yeah they're afraid they're in
this situation they're nervous if they
weren't nervous they'd be more confident
they'd engage in more negotiations and
so what happens is the older the cops
get the more fights they've been in the
better their language becomes that's
what we saw in the data recognition yeah
so I want to basically help young cops
speak like old cops as quickly as
possible interesting
you know just to get out
get out to like a rising sort where do
you think
um give me another genre of the world
where you think you know structuring the
data could have a profound impact
because if your brain is playing puzzles
and games
like I've you know obviously you're
super focused on your startup right now
which is cool and I think it's such an
important topic which is why I'm happy
to have you on
just take me out of that for a quick
second just knowing you're a human being
living life and I think we all do this
whatever our framework is we can see it
in other places yeah give me a four
insta you know this is almost like maybe
inspiring someone who's also strong at
this be like hey did you look at what's
going on with the surf current or like
with soccer or like where else is do you
see like a huge opportunity right now in
this anything stand out yeah because I
come from sort of a market-centrics
background what I mean is I think about
how liquidity interacts with each other
right building trading strategies I
think very deeply about liquidity
Dynamics and matching engines blockchain
is basically markets for networks that's
how I think about it it's like networks
interacting with each other in a market
sense so an example would be Gary my car
is behind yours my car is going to be
able to negotiate with your car to get
out of the way so I can pass you and
maybe I pay you some fee and and so cars
are gonna be okay stop right there yeah
like that I like the way Dustin
responded and my brain did the same
thing and I was shockingly quiet
um that was [__] amazing to your
point self you know this is all goes to
the Techno I keep telling my friends I'm
like because I am profoundly stunned
that people think technology stops in
their live Hood
I'm like you do understand that like
people were our age 40 and then like the
car was just invented at that time and
then like everything changed for the TV
or a plane I'm like ai's gonna happen
and more crazy stuff's gonna happen so
to your point self-driving cars at scale
right in the world now on networks 5G 6G
7g 13g it's gonna get fast enough no lag
time and now because I'm in a rush I'm
paying more I can actually be in my car
in 27 years nine years 99 years whenever
this happens and I could say I'm about
to pay a Vic this is exactly right this
is exactly what blockchain's gonna do
makes so much damn sense I'm literally
going to be in an interface and be like
I need to actually get there in seven
because I could get there in 17 minutes
in travel time but it's the traffic
that's going to make 39 so now I'm gonna
pay the drivers in front of me a vig to
actually get me there in 17 minutes
because that is actually that valuable
to me because if I lose that 15 minutes
I might not get the business deal and
this might be worth a thousand dollars
for me
and that could be disseminated amongst
the 83 cars in front of me to or 830 for
me to get there yes yes that was an
example of how uh flocking Rat yeah well
I was just explaining how markets how I
think of blockchain is like this big
market for networks but the NLP
component of blockchain
um you asked what I think about I think
right now it's hard to know what's true
you know in the world yes and um if you
have this big network of uh you know
authenticators and consensus I think
there's a a product where we dump things
onto a blockchain and um that Network
through consensus decides whether that's
true or not and and so that'll be done
through NLP because that's going to be a
bunch of unstructured data correct
here's this article I read it got dumped
on the blockchain the chain says this
thing is true because these are
decentralized servers and nobody can
really impact them it has the capacity
for Providence and truth that the
internet and Society does not yeah
exactly through Page linking the network
can decide whether that's true those are
factual statements and something will
then be relatively true and we'll be
able to have confidence that what we're
reading is relatively factual right
because to your point like for many
years to get back 300 years or what have
you 100 I don't care where you go like
what was in a book was default into
believing like we believed it we we this
is clearly the blockchains are clearly
have the potential to replicate that
energy in the world in 100 years clearly
I agree with that I'm still pumped about
paying a thousand bucks to get to my
next meeting no but it's really powerful
yeah like I really I really do love that
okay you know before we run out of time
what have we not you know I always like
to leave five or seven ten minutes for
this you know you were coming in this
morning we're gonna have this podcast
I'm so respond I was excited about it
because I knew this would be a fun one
I'm really excited about the audience's
take on this I think we're going to be
able to bring a lot of value from these
kind of stories and meeting individuals
around the world like yourself doing
interesting things what did we not touch
on that you kind of thought we would
talk about here today kind of giving you
the open floor what did we and you can
be very selfish or anything that we
didn't talk about yeah I've raised a lot
of capital
um throughout my life whether it's Siege
or series A or B or you know even
through exits
um trulio in addition to professional VC
we've done crowdfunding and we put it up
on our website it's an invest Now button
and um I think Founders should be
thinking about crowdfunding in the
future and I really think it's
interesting because it's sort of a big
digital marketing exercise and for a
business like trulio
um it's a big digital marketing exercise
it's a call to action where these
engaged civilians want to want to be
involved somehow and this is the way
that they can and what I'm seeing is
that you know if somebody invests 100
bucks that that's fine they could be
somebody that drives a hundred thousand
dollar deal in their City because they
go to their city council they go to
their mayor and they say I want this
product in our city I'm a taxpayer we
bought cameras we're paying for storage
and so this this the idea of
crowdfunding I think is very very
interesting and important because it can
create activated ambassadors for your
brand got it so you're saying how humans
work
if I'm a human and I put 500 into an
investment through a crowdfunding no
different than like people that buy a
stock on the public market and then now
that they bought it they buy Nikes in
the store or they like like Nike you're
saying that the crowdfunding allows them
to be micro business development and
awareness engines and that that in
general from a psychology standpoint and
the strategy standpoint might be highly
interesting because it's not just about
the 409 dollars that they put in which
might be quite small in a 50 million
dollar raise it's that they may actually
trigger behavior that leads to higher
economic impact on the business that's
exactly right makes a ton of sense
especially at scale yeah if 13 000
people do that it could get real
interesting real fast it might not be
right for every business for a business
like trulio which right now is B2B right
the first hundred departments are early
adopters yeah where are you guys we're
how far along are 20 departments
um out of 18 000 in the U.S 18 000
police departments in the U.S and you're
in 20 right now so we're very very very
very early
how long has the longest one been using
it uh 16 months like since day one and
like without tooting your own horn like
give us a I assume like you're gonna be
something that's really cool yeah so we
we learned this yeah we learn to embed
academics in these departments to
measure outcomes so in this department
Alameda California and the Bay Area data
36 drop in use of force
36 percent got it in the 16 months yeah
they've had 36 percent less need for
Force because of all the training and
from the insights that we were able to
create yes because yeah officers have
better outcomes there's less
non-compliance they're less
transactional right the cops are smart
once they know their camera data is
being analyzed they're a little bit more
patient they speak differently the
machine learning and all this like I
assume the more the so at scale the more
you continue to analyze the more you're
going to get further down the pipe of
like another subtle Insight another
subtle and so so this thing gets
stronger over time yes I'm building a
virtual Sergeant I mean that's what we I
don't think cops are gonna Department's
gonna hire more cops I think they're
gonna we're gonna build virtual Bots
that automate supervision coaching and
they promote professionalism they're
going to create content for departments
do you think robot what about robots
that are like RoboCop but then why
didn't you have to think for like like
what do you think that like do you think
that's going to be wild right yeah yeah
I don't know I'm not sure if they'll be
you know robots I would definitely
listen to RoboCop more than a record
okay if a robot if a cop was like yo yo
don't like like I like to like probably
jaywalk too much here in the city like
the cops like yo I'm like yo I'm so
sorry but like if a robot did it I'd
probably run back like like the robot
would probably scare the [__] out of me
like laser me or something you know what
I mean yeah
do you think we're more likely to listen
to robots than humans I think we're more
or less likely to listen to female cops
actually we need more females I like
that they give explanation about 12
times the rate as a male makes sense
they're always they have to be more
strategic communication we do I got
three girls we're such [__] ups
um so that so that's interesting that
right to your point this is where the
data gets super duper duper duper
interesting and becomes more actionable
um I love it again I know we're running
out of time any just because I'm so
fascinated by this again everybody
listen to podcasts I think you can sense
that I'm trying some new stuff from a
from a content and marketing standpoint
please give me feedback on what you
think about obviously this is one man
one startup one subject matter but the
concept of emerging things and emerging
individuals that you may not just be
able to find every day not the same
people that are being talked about every
day uh love your feedback on this
because I I personally am enjoying this
conversation quite a bit last parting
shots appreciate you Carrie yeah
appreciate you thanks for the
opportunity of course thanks so much but
but that's very sweet but one last
parting shot like a Robocop or something
anything anything out anything else cool
or interesting from being a founder or
raising capital or anything in the
machine learning space as a Founder have
an athlete mindset you know get sleep uh
don't do drugs limit your alcohol think
about your physical being like an
athlete you know it's really really hard
and your team needs you to be making the
best decisions possible
appreciate you thanks Gary thank you sir
that was fun yeah
[Music]